so happy we're obsessed with the new
song and the new music video oh there's
so much happening to Beyond
and I love that the new video was
inspired by this colorful uh wedding and
was it inspired by any wedding in
particular I love a ghost don't we just
love a good chit chat on the TV show
that everybody can watch I got married
[Applause]
it's so interesting to me because I I
loved the whole experience but I kept it
super private for a little bit just kept
it to myself so it's nice to like share
it and just sort of be open about it
feels great I mean your husband Taiko
watiti put such beautiful oh my gosh
films and stories into the world from
JoJo rabbit what we do in the shadows I
know the film is one of my favorite
films on Earth he's so so great and I
think that's really important we're
friends and I mean you know we met long
before we decided to ruin everything we
were friends for six years that's right
because you guys were friends and then
you re-found each other at the maybe the
right time in Australia while you were
working yes I was doing the voice I do
the voice over there and yeah right
and he was making probably one of his
masterpieces he was doing the Thor movie
Yes with Marvel and uh
I don't even know how to explain
everything just went it genuinely just
went like that I mean honestly he put
his hand on my back and then
low back high back low back and that's
what I knew yeah this is a different
type of stroke yeah yes
and that's why I asked placement lower
back there is something like very
nurturing and yet yeah warm and I'll
take care of you
I mean honestly it's just it's a really
cool cool Dynamic and we both kind of do
our own thing and I'm very happy right
now
[Applause]
and we do like to report you know some
news you can news the good news too if
you will
um will you hit some headlines with us
oh yes
according to the New York Post a new
study finds that singles who use dating
apps love to do their homework before
the first date wow 38 admit to
researching their date online and 18 say
they run a full background check wow
overall women are far more likely to do
their research than men okay so Drew
before a date tell me what do you do do
you do some digging well I didn't know
that you could do a background check
because now that I know this I mean I
don't know like you think knowledge is
power
um I do notice on dating apps men can be
very mysterious and say like their
occupation is an astronaut but I'm like
I know you're not an astronaut right so
why are you messing with me now we're
off to a weird start you're being pithy
and cute but I really just want an
anchor here who are you yes yeah so like
can I trust you yes so I'm not sure I go
both ways it's almost like are you gonna
open this Pandora box what if you don't
like what you find yeah I I don't think
I like it but I do really like the idea
of being surprised you know what I mean
but then do you want to waste time you
know I'm not a Time waster what about
you did you Google your husband did you
do the whole background check thing no
because we met through friends yeah you
news again yes so I did like the
homework I did I built the scaffolding
you know what I mean so then when we got
together it was kind of like easy all
right hey next up big movie news The
Hollywood Reporter says Amazon has a new
comedy on the way starring two huge
Headliners yeah Julia Roberts Jennifer
Aniston her team up I mean get me to
this movie now now
um and we don't know much about the plot
yet just that it will be some sort of
body swapping thing like a Freaky Friday
whatnot and I just know all I know is
that I've already bought four tickets
that's all I know
I can't wait get me there right now I am
so happy this movie really can't happen
fast enough as far as I'm concerned I
mean you have two queens two legends two
of the most iconic movie stars in the
same movie
I mean some of my favorite romance you
are in yeah like Never Been Kissed is
like iconic by the way I just turned
into Josie birthday I was like
well next up travel and Leisure reports
a new survey has just revealed the best
city in the world it beat out Paris
Tokyo New York City drum roll please
here it is
oh Rita it's London
[Applause]
[Music]
food history architecture theater tea in
the afternoon London has it all and may
I ask you what is one thing that you
would recommend if we were to pop on
over to London that we can't miss I know
we're not known for our food I know
there's a very like I disagree food but
you know we do have some good
restaurants like really good sushi
places and um you know I'd like to
personally say like go walk through the
parks like the parks are stunning like
hype Park and Primrose Hill go to
Notting Hill gate because that's again a
lovely rom-com Notting Hill
walk down the market you can see all the
things everyone's screaming at you to
buy apples I mean the experience is
fantastic
and two for a pan you know you'll love
it and have a beer have a Guinness if
you don't have alcohol-free version but
you have to do fish and chips you've got
to do that
yeah what is it called is it mashed
potatoes
um
and the beans baked beans I don't like
that oh okay oh I do well I do now we're
gonna go to a commercial break and up
next Rita's stirring in the new Kung Fu
Panda as a no-nonsense bear and find out
Sarah have in common she made some
changes she made a little auditions
after this
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]